here now with more the author of trial
of the Century Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett also the author of the book
get Trump Harvard Law Professor Alan
dershowitz and former acting attorney
general Matthew Whitaker is with us guys
good to see you uh you know Greg let me
start with you tonight because one thing
you keep referring to is the
presidential records act
um conspicuously in my view absent uh
any reference to thereof why would this
be relevant in a case like this
it's the main defense and it's the
prevailing controlling law the
presidential records act a civil statute
gave Trump the right under the law to
maintain custody and control of papers
whether they're classified or not Sean
uh it's a civil not criminal statute
because it's a specific statute it takes
precedence over General statutes and
indeed for more than a decade the
Department of Justice agreed with that
it became their own established standard
they even argued it in federal court of
the Bill Clinton case stating
emphatically that Clinton was entitled
to keep whatever he wanted after leaving
office whether it was classified or not
so that's Trump's main defense and the
judge in the case
endorsed it the judge ruled the National
Archives doesn't have authority to
decide presidential records and that
seizing them from a former president is
on founded in contrary to the law so
Trump relied on that standard that
should be his defense
all right let me go to the statement
professor dershowitz today we have one
set of laws in this country and they
apply to everybody uh then we can go to
the tape that I just played uh and in
this particular case it was James Comey
admitting that Hillary had top secret
classified materials all over her
servers uh I would argue that the
leading 33 000 subpoenaed emails uh and
destroying devices that may have that
information on it that to me and maybe
I'm just old-fashioned that would that
would fit the classic definition of
obstruction to me but I'm not a
prosecutor
do we have the same standards being
applied to Hillary Clinton Joe Biden and
Donald Trump in these cases
I don't think we do and Jack Smith try
to persuade us that we do you know he's
probably listened to your show and so he
deliberately did not indict Trump under
the provision of the statute because of
my show
the provision that talks about because
of what he learned
listen he didn't indict him under the
provision that talks about negligence he
indicted him on the much higher standard
of willfulness which will make it much
harder to prove but will allow him to
say see this is distinguishable from
Hillary Clinton not arguing negligence
I'm arguing willfulness look there are
only two paragraphs out of only almost
100 in the indictment that Donald Trump
has anything to worry about their
paragraphs 34 and 35 that disclose the
tape the uh consensually recorded tape
that Trump uh allowed to take when he
spoke to a writer about a book
concerning Meadows in which he
essentially admitted that a document
that he showed him maybe just flashed it
in front of him we don't know
could have been declass Survivor it was
not Declassified those are the only two
paragraphs 30.35 that I think are
unanticipated and he has anything to
worry about the rest of them are covered
either by the records act or uh lack of
uh intent uh it's very hard to prove the
kind of level of intent but the the the
two paragraphs that are troubling the
two and and I think Trump's defense will
probably be look I was just showing off
I didn't really show him these uh of uh
materials I just let him see that we had
them he didn't read them and of course
the government doesn't have the
materials themselves and so it's going
to be hard to prove what's in them but
if I were Trump's lawyers those are the
two paragraphs I would be focusing on I
think the rest of it is duplicitous and
typical and predictable and probably not
Criminal
all right so Matt Whitaker let me go to
what James Comey said in in the three
days in October 2016. he talked about
about top secret classified information
being faxed and Hillary insisting or
asking that the heading be removed
meaning the classification but it didn't
declassify the document uh people that
didn't have clearances including a
lawyers and others also uh looking at
those documents at least 10 people they
said at the time uh foreign governments
likely having hacked into that system
and and then comey's statement that
thirty thousand emails forgetting the 33
000 she deleted you know 110 of them uh
in 52 email chains uh determined by the
owning agency to have classified
information at the time they were sent
or received eight of those chains had
top secret 36 had secret
um tell me how that this in any way
comports with the statement that was
made by Jack Smith today that we have
one set of laws in the country that
apply to everyone well the laws applied
in that case
yeah they weren't and in that Hillary
Clinton case under the Jack Smith
standard and this charging document
Hillary Clinton should have been charged
on many many counts of violating this
statute and this is the problem is the
Equal justice under the law that concept
is out the window now because again that
was just a fleeting moment in American
history I guess where the FBI director
can stand up and give somebody a pass
and now we have a the Biden
Administration you know through their
special counsel Jack Smith who directly
reports to Merrick Garland is targeting
their main political opponent and you
know listen he stood up there today also
and said that essentially he was
representing the intelligence Community
as well guess who the intelligence
Community went after in 2015 and 2016.
Donald Trump and here we go again all
right Matt Whitaker thank you Alan
dershowitz thank you Greg thank you hey
it's Will Kane click here to subscribe
to the Fox News Channel on YouTube it's
the best way to get our latest
interviews and highlights and click to
subscribe to the will Cain podcast for
full episodes right now